We have discussed the possibility of violence
tonight and into the week. The White House is
taking it seriously. They've built a new fence
around the White House to protect Donald Trump.
We'll talk about that later. Other countries,
as I've already told you, taking it seriously,
issuing travel warnings for their citizens who
plan to be in the United States. I gave you the
examples of Australia and New Zealand. And there
are others colleges. I mentioned George Washington
University in D.C. telling students plan like
it's a snow storm where you might not be able
to or might not want to go out for days.
Stockpile food. Stockpile medication. OK,
reporters for Reuters covering today's election.
We'll have protective gear in anticipation
of unrest after a bunch of incidents in
which journalists were targeted during summer
protests. Reporters are being given flak jackets,
helmets and gas masks. Plus, because we have a
global pandemic, all of the PPE that you would
need from the public health standpoint. Now,
I want to be really clear about one thing
tonight and this week there is concern about
armed Trump pests and generally about voters
being out in large angry groups. And, of course,
that's a concern. But remember that during the
anti police brutality protests over the summer,
most incidents of police, a rather I'm sorry, I'm
getting ahead of myself. Most incidents of press
being attacked, hit by rubber bullets, knocked
down, punched. It was mostly coming at the hands
of police and not protesters. That has been the
big risk. The reason it might change tonight
and this week is that Donald Trump has been
very hostile to the media for four years now.
He has been attacking the media as fake and
phony and bad people and the enemy of the people.
Trump ists often will verbally abused reporters
at Trump's rallies. Many stories about that. And
the idea is if Trump narrowly loses and claims it
was rigged, you are going to see the possibility
of escalation into physical violence against the
media, who many Trump is again see as the enemy.
That is legitimate. And I would be worried
about that. But again, reminder, until now,
the biggest risk to the press at protests
has been police officers beating reporters,
rubber bullets from armed officers hitting
reporters, not danger from actual protesters. Now,
can we step back for just a second and appreciate
how insane this headline is? Reuters Equipping
journalists covering the U.S. election with flak
jackets, helmets and gas masks. Election reporters
in the U.S. are having to be prepared like war
correspondents. This is where America is in 2020.
Other countries have offered to send us election
monitors and in fact, have sent them to 28 states.
There are eleven states in the U.S. where such
observers are banned, including many states in the
south of the United States. I know four years is
a long time. Change happens slowly. We have slowly
become desensitized to these changes. Crazy things
have become normalized. But step back for a moment
and consider how insane it is that reporters need
protective gear to cover a U.S. election because
of the threat of violence. As the president
has said, he will go to courts to try to get
mail in. Ballots thrown out won't commit to a
peaceful transfer of power while saying if he
loses, he may leave the country like a deposed
authoritarian dictator. Trump wants to be afraid
of some non-existent hypothetical Biden's America.
But look at Trump's America right now. Trump,
at his rallies continues to say, if you vote
for Biden, it's a vote for anarchy or anarchy,
as he says. If you vote for Biden, it's a vote for
low water pressure and no heating in the winter,
no cooling in the summer. Having to flush your
toilet 10 or 15 times the end of the suburbia. All
of this different stuff. Trump has been painting
a completely dystopian picture if done. If Joe
Biden were to win. But remember, Donald Trump
is president now. Look at the list of things
that are happening now that many of us would
never, ever, ever have imagined would have been
what the United. Gates is like, if I add and
again, to frame this, go back to November,
what was it? November 9th of twenty sixteen,
the day after the election, if I had told you
four years from now, this laundry list of things
will be happening in the United States. I don't
think any of you would have believed it. Very,
very few of you would have believed it. That is
where we are today. Let's deal desensitize. Let's
re sensitize ourselves to the insanity of this.
And let's hope that tonight we see the
right results. I hope you'll join me.
I will be live on YouTube Twitch and Facebook
starting just shy of seven p.m. Eastern Time.
Make sure you're also following The David
Pakman Show on Instagram at David Pakman sheft